يبدو أن هناك انخفاض في الروح المعنوية
بين قواتك ، ويبدو أن هناك
أعطال في المعدات وقضايا القيادة والسيطرة ،
سؤالي الأول هو
ما الذي يعتقد الرئيس بوتين أنه
حققه في أوكرانيا حتى الآن
بشكل جيد أولاً وقبل كل شيء
لم يحقق بعد أه  حتى الآن ونحن
نتحدث عن عملية خاصة وعسكرية
جارية
وهي مستمرة بشكل صارم وفقًا
للخطط والأغراض التي تم وضعها
مسبقًا وبالطبع أولاً وقبل كل شيء أعتقد
أننا يجب أن نتحدث عن  عن
أسباب هذه العملية يعني
لأن
أه يتحدث عن الروح المعنوية
ضدنا أه
أه في أه
بين جيشنا طبعا
أنت تدير
أه بيانات ومعلومات تأتي من
وسائل إعلام مختلفة ومن
استخباراتك لكن ربما
أه
لديك  للشك في هذه المعلومات ، عليك
أن تشك في ذلك وعليك أن تفكر مليًا
فيما إذا كانت
صحيحة أم لا
جيدًا ، إليك الشيء
الذي تعرفه يا سيد بيسكوف أم أنك تعرف
معلومات
المخابرات  لقد توقعت حقًا أن يكون الغزو
صحيحًا على الرغم مما
أخبرتنا به جميعًا أنك تعرفه من الكرملين ، لذلك
دعونا نتجاوز أننا سمعنا أيضًا
أنك تعرف المدنيين
والصحفيين الذين رأوا القوات الروسية والذين عرفوا
رويت لكن
هذا هو الحال
عندما تقول إنه لم يحقق
الرئيس بوتين لم يحقق بعد
ما تتوقعه لأن هذا
سيكون وفقًا لجانبك في
الصحافة في وسائل الإعلام التي ترعاها الدولة  في
روسيا ، وهي عملية سريعة جدًا ،
تم اقتراح أن تعرف في غضون
يومين أن
أوكرانيا ستعود إلى
روسيا الأم التي لم يتم
اقتباسها من اقتباس غير مقتبس عما حدث
وماذا تراه في المرحلة التالية
من هذا
البئر  بالطبع لن
يفكر أحد منذ البداية في
أنها عملية جادة ذات
أغراض جادة
وأعتقد أنه إذا حاولنا تذكر
تلك الأغراض ، فإن الأهداف الرئيسية
للعملية هي
التخلص من الجيش  إمكانات
أوكرانيا وهذا هو السبب في أن
جيشنا يستهدف فقط
الأهداف العسكرية والأهداف العسكرية على
أراضي أوكرانيا وليس الأهداف المدنية
لا يضرب الجيش الروسي
الأهداف المدنية الأهداف المدنية
رقم اثنين
هو ضمان أن تتغير أوكرانيا من
مركز روسي كامل
إلى مركز محايد
وبهذا المعنى ، دعونا نتذكر
أنه بعد انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي ،
تم بالفعل تحديد الوضع المحايد
في
إعلان استقلال
البلد
رقم ثلاثة
للتخلص من
الكتائب القومية والأفواج القومية
الذين هم الآن في الواقع
يعارضون روسيا.  الجنود الذين لا
يحاولون الآن التستر على أنفسهم تحت
درع المدنيين ،
وبالتالي يمهدون الطريق
لضحايا مدنيين
أم
نعم ، والذين أطلب العفو منك إذا
سمحت
لي وأيضًا للتأكد من
أن أوكرانيا
تعترف بحقيقة
أن شبه جزيرة القرم هي أيضًا  جزء لا يمكن الاستيلاء عليه
من روسيا
وأن جمهوريتي
لوغانسك ودونيتسك موجودتان بالفعل
الدول التابعة أن أوكرانيا قد فقدتها بالفعل
بعد الانقلاب الذي حدث في عام 2014.